market reason said something interesting
that the intersection of biotech and AI
it is a space that's very ripe just so I
do it before somewhere thank you do you
think of that since you invest so
heavily in biotech and you think about
it so much what do you think the impact
on AI of AI on BIOS will actually be
completely underestimated we've been
thinking and talking about this for a
number of years I'll give you just a
quick example around machine learning or
AI in if you look at a product called
Google photos which is an app you can
download it will find every minut
picture of you in your phone even ones
that you might not recognize yourself
and if you take that same technology and
apply it to something like neo antigens
which are kind of a way to detect cancer
and you apply that machine learning
technology to the search for a new
Diagnostics for cancer it's going to
revolutionize the entire healthcare
industry you're investing in a company
called Grail which is very early
diagnostic for cancer it may even
identify cancer before it becomes cancer
I'm curious about that how do you handle
things like over testing or I mean it
seems like that shouldn't be a problem
but you know the idea seems almost you
know to it's true it's a that's a liquid
biopsy company something that's been
tried for a number of years and has yet
to work but basically being able to
detect cancer as you said either the
mobile you have it or
you might be at risk for it by just
sampling your blood we don't have that
capability yet but the technical
challenges are largely solving sensing
that we know what we need to do to get
there and so I'm very confident that
this technology will exist
we hope Grail will be the developers of
it when it's a very high-risk
proposition what about gene editing
you're also invested in the company
called edit Oz what point we have to
start talking about the ethical issues
around this technology well I think it's
never too soon to talk about that the
reality is that we can edit genes right
now that CRISPR technology etc we've
invested in a number of companies there
but I think there's a flip side to that
coin there are scary things about new
technologies fire it'd be scary because
it could burn down your house but gene
editing can be scary for all the reasons
you can imagine at the same time can be
used potentially to cure children of
cystic fibrosis
I think the positives of that will far
outweigh the negatives you've had some
opinions about fairness and since we
last spoke it's only gotten worse for
theranos should Elizabeth home still be
running that company that is up to the
shareholders I would say of fairness
really so you don't think that they can
turn it around like is there is there no
hope I don't know what there is to turn
around technology apparently doesn't
exist maybe I don't have all the facts
but I don't know what there is to turn
around
the public markets haven't been kind to
the biotech sector what do you think of
that how is it impacting earlier stage
investment I think the public markets
are always wrong in the short term
usually right in the long term and I
think if you look generally speaking
long term prospects or biotech are
strong biotech like any sector falls in
and out of favor over time maybe
slightly out of favor now but the
reality is that that sector is going to
transform not only the length with the
quality and duration of our lives and so
we're very bullish Tony Fadell recently
less left nests somewhat unceremoniously
what went wrong and should we be worried
about the future of nest in Alphabet I
wouldn't be worried I think it was
reported as unceremoniously but the fact
of the matter is how many hugely
successful founders still work at the
big companies that acquired them
Stephen Chad founded YouTube and they're
not at Google anymore so as it wasn't
shocking to me that Tony decided he
wanted to go and do something new and
this continues on and will continue on
but the ideal to have a founder led
company at least that's the idea that's
perpetuated in silico I don't know but
said you know I think the reality is
that there are different leaders for
different times Eric Schmidt was the CEO
of Google at the right time it wasn't an
outstanding CEO now Larry's a CEO and he
would argue that this is the right time
for him to be in that position so I
think speaking of the environment you
guys are investors in uber we were just
raised multi-billions of dollars wrote
about CD raising billions of dollars I
just Marc Andreessen and his his his
firm just raised a billion and a half
dollars we passed the idea of a downturn
or are we still in one where are we I
think again it depends on if it's that
old adage the difference between a
recession and depression is recessions
when you're out of work and a depression
is when I'm out of work it depends on
your point of view
so venture capitalists have had a pretty
easy time raising money
for the most part I would say especially
successful ones like Marc but he should
always have a pretty easy time raising
money as long as he's successful so that
doesn't shock me
uber raising lots of money it's a hugely
successful company on a tear so that's
not very surprising either are there
other companies getting left behind
though that can't race I don't know
they're getting left behind but
rationality is returning over the last
six months to the market and I think
what you'll see is companies rather than
raising money on what they might do will
be raising money on what they have done
and you'll probably see more IPOs over
the next 18 months than we've seen which
has been basically zero over the last
six to ten months speaking of different
leaders for different times there's a
presidential election happening right
now and I'm curious what do you think
Hillary Clinton means for Silicon Valley
what do you think it's a great question
I'm not super political I hope whatever
leader that we choose collectively
becomes a lot more thoughtful about the
issues and less headline-grabbing
and more leadership and I'm not
convinced that we're at that place yet
and so I think we mean well I think I
think we all need to get involved to get
informed on the issues there's some
really important and sometimes tragic
things going on in the world right now
and we need to be important about those
things and at least both
and not just bicker online and yell at
each other over Facebook or Twitter but
instead actually look at the plants and
proposals and decide what makes sense
for you and your family and your life
and friends and and at least both maybe
do more than that